happy Marvel Monday youtubers you guys
request a new spider-man a bunch of
people got to visit this set and they
explained a whole bunch of new cool
stuff about the Iron Man spider suit so
I'll explain what's going on they even
named drop venom if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's a Spider Man giveaway
that's going on that I'll explain at the
end of the video but a bunch of people
got to visit the Spider Man set so we
learned a whole bunch of stuff about the
Spider suit it is truly an Iron Man suit
I don't want to flat-out call it the
iron spider suit because for some reason
people get really upset when you call it
that because it's not colored gold and
red like the iron spider suit of the
comics but it's literally a copy of an
Iron Man suit only even more advanced
that's right it's got more advanced
technology than Iron Man's last suit now
that doesn't make it more powerful
Iron Man definitely walks around with
weapons all over him war machine is the
only person who visibly looks like he
has more weapons than Iron Man on his
suit but that's just because the big
joke is that war machine is wearing Iron
Man's 80's hand-me-downs so there's any
confusion Iron Man always wears the most
powerful suits but spider-man because he
had the most recent upgrade and because
of the way the suit works its
form-fitting it almost looks like cloth
it's just that much more advanced than
his last Iron Man suit I would say black
panther probably has like the next step
up from that because of the vibranium
weave Iron Man does not have access to
that but here are all the things that
they revealed that the suit can do one
it has the drone that we saw in the
trailer it has different iviews it has
changing web dispersal which is actually
this scene here is a mirror of a
previous Iron Man scene from the first
Iron Man movie you may have missed it
the weapons burger was a 230 you missed
it
[Music]
that is so cool but on top of that it
has its own Jarvis
that's right spider-man suit has its own
version of an AI system we don't know
what it's called it's not called Jarvis
as far as we know people have just been
reporting that it has its own Jarvis
that doesn't mean that it's called
Jarvis because Iron Man is using the
Friday system now because Jarvis was
used to create the vision
good evening Bob so unless you
resurrected the name for the suit he
built for spider-man it's going to be
called something else so it'll be fun to
see what that's called it'll probably be
some nod to spider-man lore but Tom
Holland revealed that he would love to
fight venom in a future spider-man movie
in Amy Pascal and you know everyone's
worried about spider-man leaving the MCU
she reiterated the statement about how
crazy was that they got all the studio's
to agree to work together
Disney Sony and Marvel in that the sky
was the limit for the future of the
franchise they have the second
spider-man Home Coming movie whatever
that movie is going to be called they
already have it planned they're going to
be making it with Marvel but the
contract that they have to share the
character is up after that movie so she
said they're trying not to worry about
making those other movies anything that
might come in the future
they're just worrying about the stuff
right now and the politics would work
themselves out so I guess you could look
at that as a way for her to reassure
people that they will work politics out
spider-man will stay in the MCU which
was kind of my feeling when I posted
that video last week it sounds like an
insurmountable problem you know Sony why
would they ever share character they're
making so much money from but it just
means the long-term everything will
probably work out they also revealed
some really cool stuff about the vulture
and his team that he's putting together
during homecoming they said you know he
is one of the people who wins a contract
to clean up the [ __ ] our invasion so way
back when the first Avengers movie
happens he has this awesome windfall but
then throughout the MCU as things get on
damage control is created and Tony Stark
steals all that work from him so he
can't feed his family and like he says
in the trailer I take care of my family
don't come after me I'll take down
everyone you love they say that he gets
most of his flight tech from the shatori
invasion but a couple of other places so
they're like oh okay what's the other
technology that's leftover from big
battles in the Avengers one really cool
example of that is they say that the
Shocker gets his hands on the battering
ram that crossbones used during civil
war
I'll do anything to get my fans shell
game now one of the Masters pale oh
there you are you son of a [ __ ] I've
been waiting for them they said there
would be no villains from previous
spider-man films so I know Osborn exists
in the MCU because of the Spidey sharing
arrangement all the spider-man
characters exist in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but they said because this
movie is meant to be young teenage Peter
Parker ground level looking up growing
up in a world where the Avengers exist
they wanted to do as many different
things as possible from the ground up so
Uncle Ben is in the movie but he's not
literally in the movie they were kind of
coy about that they confirm they do
address it but like they said that the
Aunt May character because Peters so
much younger she's so much younger she's
more of an older sister to him and Tony
Stark is more of an older brother the
joke is is that Peter Parker calls him
all the time way more than he's supposed
to so you have to imagine Tony Stark
genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist is busy doing big
Avengers level stuff and he has
spider-man calling him every five
minutes asking him stuff about the suit
that's why he turns to his friend Ned
leaves who is kind of a version of Genki
from the ultimate spider-man comics
there's a lot of ultimate spider-man
theories because they're borrowing from
that universe so much I think mostly
they chose to mine those comics just
because they are so different from the
main spider-man comics and they've been
using the main spider-man comics for all
the previous spider-man films so give me
all your theories about the next
spider-man Home Coming movie pulling
from more ultimate spider-man stuff that
they haven't done before and if it
wasn't clear they did confirm the
ultimate Iron Man variant of Tony
Stark's armor you can barely tell on the
legs here the coloration is a little bit
different it's very similar and look to
his Civil War suit it sounds like
they're not going to be doing
traditional spider-man stuff like Doctor
Octopus Norman Osborn sinister six even
till way further down the line they said
that like this version of spider-man you
see him swinging through the backyard
here is working his way up to being the
spider-man that swings down giant
skyscrapers in mid
town so a lot of that will just take
place over the next couple of movies
that he starves and we have this
spider-man homecoming movie ground level
spider-man just learning about his suit
Avengers infinity war dealing with
cosmic level problems then coming back
for that second last supposed spider-man
Marvel movie so if you look at the
schedule here that second Avengers film
is May 3rd 2019 the last spider-man
movie that's supposed to be with Marvel
is July 5th so I think way before then
they'll have something to announce like
hey we've extended our arrangement in
all things being equal I don't think
that they would wait till that second
Spider Man film to announce that they
had extended that arrangement
so maybe Comic Con 2018 they'll have
something to announce but Marvel is
known for making off-cycle announcements
like they did it when they did their big
phase 3 announcement this is Kevin Feige
explaining why they had to make their
big phase 3 announcement and couldn't do
it at Comic Con way way back before
civil war came out we wanted to do this
at Comic Con this year and things were
not said things for Civil War were not
said yet things for again guardians
hadn't come out yet
so the comfort was dating a few of the
other movies wasn't set yet so the plan
has been in a few weeks before Comic Con
we realized we weren't going to be able
to do everything we wanted to do to
decide okay let's do something we even
haven't done a long time or have never
done which is which is a singular event
just to announce what we have when it's
ready and I thought that might be early
August of deadline is September and ends
up being today so do not freak out if
they get to Comic Con this summer and
they bring a bunch of spider-man stuff
but they don't say anything about the
future of the character after that
second spider-man movie there's just so
many people on both sides of this that
want to see this continue that they're
going to do everything they can to
figure the politics out like Amy Pascal
said the politics will figure themselves
out so let me know in the comments what
other really awesome stuff do you think
that the Iron Man spider-man suit can do
and when do you think during the movie
he's going to get it back from Iron Man
because this big battle seems like the
climax of the film him having to step up
without the help of Big Brother Tony
Stark I still love that idea so much Big
Brother Tony Stark not uncle Tony Stark
or surrogate father Tony Stark
that says a lot about Tony Stark's mind
space in this movie he's probably
incredibly uncomfortable with the idea
of being someone's father so leave all
your requests for bonus videos in the
comments below there was a new guardians
of the galaxy two trailers that just
dropped so I'll do a video for that next
that should be out in a couple hours but
congratulations to wither boss gaming
you won last week's Spider Man giveaway
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for that
to post click here for brand new Rick
and Morty and click here for brand new
spider-man homecoming thank you so much
for watching let's high five I'll see
you guys in that next video